new video posted by the Las Vegas
review-journal show's courageous
civilians stepping in to help during the
Las Vegas shooting bring the guy in the
chair with the chest
the injured were loaded into the back of
this pickup truck the driver then sped
down Las Vegas Boulevard until he found
an ambulance
dozens of paramedics fire fighters and
police officers also rushed to help when
the shooting began
Audriana Diez spoke with three first
responders who did just that she joins
us from inside a fire station in Las
Vegas
Audriana good morning good morning we
sat down with two Clark County
firefighters in a Las Vegas metropolitan
Police Officer who were at the scene
Sunday night now five days later they're
speaking about why they acted without
hesitation and the outpouring of
gratitude that's followed I just felt
like if I was gonna get shot up
I was gonna get shot there's nothing I
can do about it but what I know I can do
is help a lot of people off duty
firefighter Travis Haldeman was in the
crowd with his wife when gunfire stopped
the music
he told her to run and rushed to a man
shot in the leg
I've taken my belts off wrapped it
around his leg and made a quick
tourniquet out of it threw him on my
back and started running with him on my
back towards the medical tent
I started getting texts on my phone
police officer Bert Hughes was off the
clock and getting ready for bed the kids
were sleeping
my wife was up she didn't want me to go
but she understood that I needed to go
and give her a kiss and headed out the
door what did you say to her
see you in the morning fire captain Joe
Gabe was at the scene in minutes that's
him in the helmet we've been put through
this type of training that allowed us to
just instinctually act those instincts
also kept Haldeman going
he helped at least half a dozen victims
to safety including Riley goal guard who
was shot in the back and lost feeling in
her legs I wrote in with her to the
hospital you stayed with her I did yeah
I got home around 3:30 I'd say in the
morning and changed my clothes they're
covered in other people's blood gave my
wife a big hug and a kiss she must've
been happy to see you yeah yeah it's a
hug and kiss I'll never forget he's
visited goal guard in the hospital twice
she'd stood for the first time it's a
feeling it's hard to describe it's the
same way as when you're kids standing
for the first time or take their first
steps you know Joe how are you different
now than you were before this Oh see now
you gonna make me cry I think about my
guys a lot more you see how they're
coping with it and in their own families
it hurts you know it hurts to see Travis
hurt you guys are a family and this has
just tightened those bonds 100% there's
one bad person that showed up to that
concert that night and thousands that
have showed up sense to help out whether
it's their own blood their own money
that is Las Vegas five years ago Las
Vegas started a special interagency
training program between the police and
fire department so that they respond
together and faster to incidents like
mass shootings that training likely
saved lives and is now being used as a
model in other cities
Charlie madrina thanks thousand stories
of the instinctive desire of people to
help yeah you always expect the first
responders to be strong and effective to
know what they're doing but to show how
deeply it affects them too
I love Adriana for sharing that story
with us and I like to that Bert's words
came true when he said I'll see you in
the morning for all three of those guys
humanity of those zeros very nice